good morning hick it's Tuesday I spent
the weekend hiking in Kentucky with my
friends we were in Red River Gorge where
the views are absolutely phenomenal this
is an annual trip and it's always one of
the highlights of my year I I had a
mustache incidentally because last year
everyone shaved their beards into a
mustache but this year only I did so I
looked like a weirdo as opposed to last
year when we were just five mustachioed
guys walking through the woods which
didn't look weird at all Red River Gorge
is just stupidly beautiful there are
mountains and cliffs and all kinds of
Adventure from scrambling up Rock faces
to walking through creek beds and most
of all there are views it's a funny word
view a view is what you're giving this
video of course it's also what you can
see at any given moment anyone who can
see and has their eyes open has a view
as you're watching me my view is of a
panoramic scene of The Valleys below and
the ridges in the distance but as I'm
recording these words I'm back home so
my view is of an unmade bed a Catherine
Murphy painting and a window into the
gray Indiana winter I always have a view
but the idea of great views is that
you're aware that you have a view you're
seeing the world in a way that feels new
or vast or visually overwhelming you're
viewing something great and a little
scary which is how Rudolph Otto
described the sacred the mysterium
tremendum he called it a great view is
supposed to evoke the tremendous mystery
but it never quite worked for me like I
remember once in college I drove across
the country with my friends Ransom and
Cathy to visit the Grand Canyon and we
watched at dawn as the sun rose and the
Shadows crept down the canyon wall and I
just wasn't that impressed like don't
get me wrong it's a Grand Canyon I'm not
deeply versed in Canyon lore but I
imagine that the Grand Canyon is
probably an absolutely worldclass topof
its field kind of Canyon but for me
personally at the age of 20 having
driven 1,800 miles to see this great
wonder of the world it felt a little
underwhelming in the end I'm not sure
that I'm a views kind of person maybe
because I don't have a particularly
Vivid visual imagination and maybe
because I have a rather intense fear of
heights and amount of height is
sometimes correlated with quality of
view like Red River Gorge is one of
those aggressively beautiful places
where the Wonder shouts from the
mountaintops and natural stone arches
and I do love it but of course I'm not
really there for the views and what I
love about it isn't really what I can
see I am there for the togetherness for
the feeling that my life is bound up in
these other lives for the story stories
we've told and retold to each other for
over a decade now for the making and
recalling of shared
memories I do not get the feeling of
mysterium tremendum from the views but
instead from the feeling of
interconnectedness not just to my
friends but also to the ground we trod
for me the Wonder is in every footfall
and every pine tree what an astonishment
it is to be not just with beauty
or with nature but to be at
all what a
wonder that we get to be here for a
little
while Hank I'll see you on Friday